قال والي ولايه غرب دارفور خميس عبد الله
ابا بكر للجزيره ان عدد القتلى في الولايه
نتيجه تحول الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الى مواجهات قبليه ارتفع الى حوالي
850 قتيلا بينهم نحو 200 طفل واكد الوالي
ان عدد الجرحى ارتفع الى اكثر من 2600
بينهم نحو 700 طفل في ظل انهيار القطاع
الصحي بعد تعرض المستشفيات والمدى
الصيدليات ومخازن المنظمات العامله في
الحقل الطبي للتدمير ودع الوالي المجتمع
الدوليه للتدخل العاجل في غرب دارفور
ووصفها بالولايه المنكوبه بعد ان اصبح كل
سكان مدينه الجنينه عاصمه الولايه بلا
ماوى وبلا غذاء فضلا عن تدمير معظم مصادر
المياه والانقطاع الكامل الكهربائي
والاتصالات واستمرار تعرض المدينه للقصف
بمدافع الهاون